welcome to the nearly wet day that's it
uh I don't even know the song the old
song from a newlywed game but it is
fantastic if right now editors can put
it in there we go okay here we go
are you two ready yes okay I think you
need to know what's at stake here guys
so the loser does not get to go into the
beautiful hot tub right there but rather
that frigid cold shower ha ha you better
than okay
a lot of baby a how much do you get a
shower cap I don't want to get my hair
Oh cute you've been on TV too long okay
here we go ready yeah number one what
was your most memorable kiss that the
two of you shared your we ran out all I
know okay are we ready three two one
flip the first one yeah after the first
impression yeah the first impression
rose
yeah
what does Sean think is his best
physical asset do I think
good thinking so much that's right yeah
look you two but if I would have been
mine then it would been your what yeah
what is Caitlin's guilty food pleasure
you do know this
what if she just loved to pig out on but
then after she probably goes why did I
do that what it is oh I knew you've been
everything I said I know you have this
chocolate who's that chocolate is one of
them Sean you're one step closer to that
shower my friend okay
who would Kaitlyn say is her celebrity
crush oh yes he's killed my heart ready
Oh Holly Rudd good show I love are you
so cute okay what is the first concert
the two of you went to together and flip
them
oh shoot oh yes their expel it it was
sure it was the same way